the new york times has just published a
three-part i think seven bazillion word
expose
shocking undercover
reporting on tucker carlson to expose
the shocking fact that tucker is
conservative
so
when when the libs come out they say
we've got a disinformation board we're
not going to stop conservative speech we
just want to stop disinformation the
problem is they define disinformation
and misinformation as conservative
speech
so i'll give you an example the new york
times is giving up the whole game here
the new york times says they've
identified five
areas of disinformation misinformation
where where tucker carlson is spreading
dangerous fake news okay what are the
five claims that tucker has allegedly
made that are such shocking
disinformation misinformation that the
libs want to censor number one we've got
it right here this is right from the new
york times
that there
accusations that there is a ruling class
intent on controlling the lives of
normal people and censoring anyone who
stands in its way
they're saying that's misinformation
the observation that there is a group of
people who have political power who are
trying to censor us which they just told
us there is if we say if we repeat back
to them what they just told us that's
dangerous misinformation
that's one that's the first thing tucker
said second one replacement through
immigration
assertions that there is an intentional
effort to replace native-born americans
with immigrants that immigration takes
away the resources and power of
native-born americans
is that controversial is that even up
for question now that
the liberals brag about that there was a
famous piece infamous piece in the new
york times written by michelle goldberg
saying we can replace them
the new york times and other liberal
outlets have been bragging for years
about the demographic problem for
republicans because republicans do much
better among native-born americans and
they do a whole lot worse among
immigrants and so as the immigrant
portion of the population explodes
because we're taking in a million legal
immigrants per year and 2 million
illegal immigrants per year probably
more actually this year that the
consequence of this is going to be bad
news for republicans and it's a
demographic demise for them
they've been bragging about this for
years
even though the majority of americans
not just of republicans
but a ton of democrats too want
drastically less immigration legal and
illegal
the ruling class keeps pushing it
because it benefits them politically
the big corporations get cheap labor the
democrats get easy votes and that's that
is that that's a shocking dangerous
conspiracy theory no that's
that's their published self-professed
strategy shifting gender roles argument
this is this is the third horrible
dangerous idea that tucker has allegedly
talked about arguments that feminism and
challenges to gender norms have
diminished masculinity contributed to
falling birth rates and led to the
demise of traditional family structures
they redefined the family they redefined
marriage and now they're chopping off
kids genitals i i don't think that's a
conspiracy theory
there they are now you now have
democrats from the lowest level all the
way up to the white house crying jensaki
was crying on camera because the
republicans might not let all of these
perverts pump little kids full of
cross-sex hormones and sterilize them
she was literally shedding real tears
over that shocking dangerous
misinformation discrimination against
white people instances in whis in which
mr carlson speaks of racism against
white people and plays down racism
against people of color there is only
one race of people that you well
sort of one and a half races of people
that you are allowed to legally
discriminate against in america it is
white people primarily and for whatever
reason sometimes asians get lumped into
this specifically when it comes to
college admissions asians get white
privilege when it comes to college
admissions
but the only group that it is not only
legal but socially acceptable to
discriminate against is white people
it's called affirmative action that's
the policy the policy is
treat white people more harshly than
other people
whatever you think you can defend the
policy you can oppose the policy but
that is the policy that's all that it is
and and furthermore if you go on
television right now and you say
black people are terrible i hate black
people or mexican people are terrible i
hate or asian people are terrible you
you will be ostracized from society but
if you go on television and say white
people are really bad they're evil they
need to apologize for their skin color
you'll get a show on cnn or msnbc
as a matter of social mores it's the
only group you're allowed to insult and
encourage to insult so it doesn't seem
like a shocking conspiracy theory to me
and then furthermore
this is number five that they accuse
tucker of destruction of society
warnings about the destruction of
society civilization and traditional
values we are transiting little children
i think we're i think we're there
i think we're about wherever sodom and
gomorrah were i think we're about
i think we're turning that up to 11 now
okay if that was 10 i think we're
turning it up to 11. the intrepid
reporter for the new york times karen
yurish
just went on msnbc to give her report
about watching tucker carlson's tv show
a few times she says it was it's way
more dangerous than she expected karen i
want to ask you what it was like for you
to watch all these
hours of tucker carlson's show
it was
revealing in a way that i can't even
describe i mean i had no idea i had not
watched the show before
this project and
once um
once i did i realized that what we
wanted to do um would
create would be to create an immersive
experience
so that
the people um
who read the new york times who most
likely don't watch the show on a regular
basis could feel what it's like because
i think it's easy to dismiss
um
to dismiss what he's saying
as you know just another
cable tv
news host but he's he's way more
powerful and and the content is way more
dangerous than
um i think what what
anybody realizes unless you're watching
the show on a daily basis
way more dangerous this is an important
word what do they mean by dangerous
do they mean it's going to threaten
people's physical safety probably not
the democrats are not generally so
worried about that they just leaked for
instance this court opinion the purpose
of which was to threaten the physical
safety of the conservatives on the
supreme court we just spent two years of
mostly peaceful riots where the libs
not only
rioted but encouraged the riots we're
not just talking about street thugs that
we're going out throwing molotov
cocktails we're talking about democrats
in the highest echelons of power
supporting with their own money and with
their own voices the rioting
maxine waters saying this was even years
ago this was at the beginning of the
trump administration get up in their
faces go find republicans when they're
out in public go to their homes where
their children sleep and yell and push
back on them and say you're not wanted
here encouraging them
elected democrats you had
plenty of democrats going in and
supporting the blm rights kamala harris
who's now the vice president of the
united states allegedly kamala harris
comes out and tweets out
a fund to go bail out the rioters not to
bail out the mostly peaceful protesters
the mostly peaceful protesters didn't
get
arrested to go bail out rioters
staffers for joe biden did the same
thing so i don't think it's that
why are they freaking out now
they're freaking out now because they
might not be able to kill babies
wherever they want in america so i don't
it's not that kind of danger
we're not talking about real physical
danger
we're talking about danger to the
political order so why are they going
after tucker why aren't they going after
other
conservative hosts on television
because tucker is a little bit different
okay the liberals are fine to tolerate
the
old order of conservatives using a very
small array of talking points to kind of
seem like they're pushing back on the
liberals but not actually threatening
their power they're fine with that
they're ha the liberals are happy to
have court jester conservatives
they actually need the corchester
conservatives they need the squishes
they even need the people who put up a
good show but then when push comes to
shove when the when the battle is really
getting intense kind of back down a
little bit they like that because if
they have corchester conservatives it
legitimizes the liberals power they but
they don't like it when the
conservatives actually threaten what
they're doing
this is something that tucker does
really well on tv this is something in
the world of podcasts that i really try
to focus on in this show this show is
not simply owning the libs i like owning
the libs i drink out of my leftist
year's tumblr my first book was a blank
book called reasons to vote for
democrats i am not above owning the libs
i think it's very fun but we've got to
do more than just own the libs and
frankly if we want to own the libs
actually own the libs and actually get
some political power back we can't just
use the same old republican talking
points we've got to think a little bit
differently maybe about trade maybe
about immigration maybe about the way we
use language maybe about the way we
wield political power we've got to think
a little bit differently we need some
tough love for our side my book with
words speechless is in many ways tougher
on conservatives than it is on liberals
because i think conservatives have been
playing into the left's hands and we got
to change that we've got to go in and
change our tactics that's the same kind
of thing what i'm saying on podcasting
it's the same kind of thing tucker's
saying on tv and he's saying it to about
four million people a night which is why
the libs are so upset
that's why they're going after that's
what the danger is it's the danger to
their polit political hegemony
that tucker is really threatening
they go after us too i mean the media
matters has tried to get me canceled for
years now
but it's something that tucker is doing
tucker right now just has the spotlight
on him he's the biggest guy on cable
news so
they
attack him
dangerous they're not they're not
talking about physical danger here's my
proof that the new york times is not
worried about physical danger the new
york times just ran an obit for a
terrorist who died an american domestic
terrorist who was associated with the
leftist group the weather underground
this is kathy boudine
here's the first
tweet about the obit from the new york
times kathy boudine who was a member of
the weather underground took part in the
murderous 1981 hold up of a brinks
armored truck died on sunday she was 78.
okay fair enough that pretty much sums
it up but then they deleted that tweet
and they changed it here was the new
tweet
kathy boudin a member of the weather
underground imprisoned for her role in a
fatal robbery but who later helped
former inmates died at 78.
that's a little softer
so they deleted the first one and put up
the new one because
the new york times readers and
leadership and editors felt they were
being a little too harsh on the felon
murderer domestic terrorist
a woman who participated in this robbery
that killed two police officers in new
york one security guard and seriously
injured another security guard
though i'm not i'm not saying that we
need to you know spike the football on
this woman's grave but she was a
domestic terrorist and now she's dead
okay a lot of people die a lot of people
get obituaries i think the new york
times got it right the first time but
they couldn't they it was too harsh the
left has too much of a soft spot for
domestic terrorists especially the
weather underground they've been fetting
the the weather underground for decades
now including this woman this woman
after she got out of the can for some
reason she was permitted out of prison i
don't know why if you kill multiple
people and you're convicted of felony
murder i think you should at the very
least stay in prison for life but they
let her out
and she became a professor at columbia
university and she became i kid you not
the co-director and co-founder of the
columbia center for justice
for justice a radical leftist terrorist
who actually acted on her radicalism and
killed people became the director of the
center
for justice
lib's fine with that soft on that the
dane the danger for the libs is not
having leftist terrorists running around
on the streets the danger for the libs
would be not having the the leftist
terrorists running around in the street
the danger for the libs would be
changing the power structure such that
leftist terrorists don't get out of
prison don't get to teach at our schools
don't get to do whatever they want
that's the threat
to them
glad you liked that clip now ding ding
ding ring that bell subscribe get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you